>>> THIS MORNING THE FIRST
SUBPOENAS ISSUED BY THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION.
THE COMMITTEE IS ASKING FOR
DOCUMENTS AND TESTIMONY FROM
FOUR OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
CLOSEST ADVISERS.
JOINING ME NOW ELIE HONIG AND
FORMER ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY
FOR THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW
YORK.
WHO IS ON THE LIST?
WHAT DOES IT TELL US?
.
>> THIS IS A BOLD FIRST STEP BY
THE COMMITTEE.
IT TELLS US THEY ARE LOOKING
SQUARELY AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND
SQUARELY AT FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP.
FOUR SUBPOENAS WENT OUT.
MARK MEADOWS, FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF TO FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP.
OBVIOUS PICK.
HE WAS BY THE PRESIDENT'S SIDE.
THE COMMITTEE IS GOING TO WANT
TO KNOW EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED
THAT DAY, EVERY CONVERSATION,
EVERY PHONE CALL.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO ASK
HIM.
DAN SKAVINO, COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR.
HE WAS THERE.
THE COMMUNICATIONS STRATEGY OF
FORMER PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS LEADING UP TO THE
EVENTS ON JANUARY 6th.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WAS THIS
PREPLANNED?
DID THEY KNOW THIS IS COMING.
.
>> HE IS ALSO THE TWEET MASTER.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT HIS
TWEETS WERE AND WHAT THEY WERE
DESIGNED TO DO.
>> TWEETING AWAY, DOING THE
VIDEOS, THAT KIND OF THING.
STEVE BANNON IS BACK.
THIS IS INTERESTING.
THEY ARE FOCUSING AT THE WILLARD
HOTEL ON JANUARY 5th, THE DAY
BEFORE DURING AN EFFORT TO
PERSUADE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO
BLOCK THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
ELECTION THE NEXT DAY.
SO, AGAIN, WHAT WENT INTO THE
PLANNING HERE, WHAT WAS THE
SPENT.
A REALLY INTERESTING ONE, PATEL,
PENTAGON OFFICIAL AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
THEY WANT TO KNOW ABOUT HIS
INVOLVEMENT REGARDING PLANNING
FOR SECURITY AT THE CAPITOL
JANUARY 6th AND RESPONDING TO
EVENTS THAT FOLLOWED THE ATTACK.
SO THEY ARE GOING RIGHT TO THE
INNER CIRCLE HERE.
.
>> TALK ABOUT THE NEXT LEGAL
STEPS, HOW IT WILL PLAY OUT.
>> WE KNOW DONALD TRUMP WILL TRY
TO GET IN THE WAY HERE.
HE'S ALREADY SAID HE WILL INVOKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE TO TRY TO
BLOCK THE COMMITTEE.
THERE'S AN INTERESTING LEGAL
QUESTION, WHO GETS TO INVOKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE?
IS IT THE CURRENT PRESIDENT OR
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WHOSE
COMMUNICATIONS ARE AT ISSUE.
NOW, NO FEDERAL COURT EVER RULED
SQUARELY ON THIS.
HOWEVER, THERE IS PRECEDENT
TELLING US IT'S THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT.
FOR EXAMPLE, GEORGE W. BUSH
EARLY IN HIS PRESIDENCY GOT A
SUBPOENA FROM BILL CLINTON'S
ADMINISTRATION, AND IT WAS
GEORGE W. BUSH, CURRENT
PRESIDENT, WHO MADE THE DECISION
ON EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE NOT THE
PRIOR PRESIDENT.
IT IS MEANT TO PROTECT THE
PRESIDENT, NOT ANY ONE
INDIVIDUAL.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT.
THEY CAN SAY MY TESTIMONY MIGHT
INCRIMINATE ME.
PEOPLE HAVE TAKEN THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT BEFORE.
THERE IS VERY LITTLE CONGRESS
CAN DO TO FORCE THEM TO TESTIFY.
FINALLY, JOHN, KEEP AN EYE ON
THE CALENDAR HERE.
THE SUBPOENAS HAVE A VERY QUICK
TURN-AROUND DATE.
THE COMMITTEE WANTS DOCUMENTS ON
THE 7th, TWO WEEKS FROM TODAY.
THEY WANT TESTIMONY FROM PATEL
AND BANNON ON THE 14th.
AND SCAVINO AND MEADOWS ON THE
15th.
>> THERE IS A TWIST NOW.
.
>> RIGHT.
SO WHAT CONGRESS CAN DO, IF THEY
WANT, IS THEY CAN -- IF THEY
DECIDE TO HOLD THESE PEOPLE IN
CONTEMPT, RIGHT, IF THEY DON'T
COMPLY, AND I THINK IT'S A SAFE
BET THEY WON'T COMPLY.
WE WILL HOLD YOU IN CONTEMPT AND
MAKER GARLAND WILL HAVE A HUGE
DECISION TO MAKE.
THEY CAN ISSUE CRIMINAL CHARGES.
BIG DECISION BY MAKER GARLAND.
IT WILL ALLOW THEM TO SPEED UP
THE CALENDAR QUITE A BIT.
>> A TOOL DEMOCRATS DID NOT HAVE
BECAUSE IT WAS THE BARR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>>> IF HE WANTS TO PRESS
CRIMINAL CHARGES IF PEOPLE DON'T
COMPLY WITH IT, HE CAN.
>> IT WILL TAKE MONTHS.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT BEFORE.
THAT HE WANTS THE WAY THE
COMMITTEE CAN SHORTCUT HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THE COURTS AND DELAY.
>>> ELIE HONIG, THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
>>> ONE OF THE TARGETS A
LONG-TIME ADVISER TO FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, STEVE BANNON.
AS REPORTED IN THE NEW BOOK
"PERIL," BANNON TOLD TRUMP,
QUOTE, WE ARE GOING TO KILL THE
BIDEN PRESIDENCY IN THE CRIB.
THIS WEEK BANNON APPEARED TO
CONFIRM IT ON HIS PODCAST.
HE PLAYED A CLIP OF COSTA
TALKING ABOUT THIS REPORTING AND
THEN BANNON RESPONDED.
.
>> WE NEED TO KILL THE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY IN THE CRIB.
THAT WAS THE PHRASE BASED ON OUR
REPORTING IN THAT CONVERSATION.
>> YEAH.
BECAUSE LEGITIMACY.
IT KILLED ITSELF.
BUT WE TOLD YOU FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING JUST EXPOSE IT.
JUST EXPOSE IT.
NEVER BACK DOWN.
NEVER GIVE UP.
AND THIS THING WILL IMPLODE.
>> WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS FOR
BANNON, THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE, AND FOR UMP DID YOU?
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT WITH CNN
LEGAL ANALYST AND HOUSE
JUDICIARY COUNSEL AMBASSADOR
NORMAN EISEN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT THIS DOES
MEAN.
ON ONE HAND HE HAS THIS PLAN
DETAILED IN THIS BOOK "PERIL."
HE SEEMS TO SAY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ILLEGITIMATE.
WE JUST EXPOSED IT.
>> BRIANNA, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
BACK ON THE PROGRAM.
THE RAMIFICATIONS ARE SERIOUS
FOR BANNON AND EVEN MORE SERIOUS
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
DON'T ACCEPT THAT AFTER THE FACT
SPIN ON BANNON'S PODCAST.
WE'RE GOING TO KILL IT IN THE
CRIB.
AND HIS PUBLIC STATEMENTS LIKE
ALL HELL IS GOING TO BREAK
LOOSE, IT'S VERY CLEAR TO
PROSECUTORS, CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS WHO ARE LOOKING AT
THIS, THAT THESE ARE FIGHTING
WORDS.
AND WE KNOW THAT BANNON, NOW WE
KNOW THAT BANNON WAS MEETING
WITH, TALKING TO THOSE AROUND
THE JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION IN
ITS RUN-UP, INCLUDING THE DAY
BEFORE DONALD TRUMP.
SO I THINK THIS REALLY PUTS A
BULLSEYE ON BANNON FOR
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS, AND
IT MAKES HIM A CRITICAL WITNESS
IN POSSIBLE CRIMINAL PROSECUTION
OF TRUMP.
WE KNOW THAT IS PERCOLATING, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA.
>> WELL, CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
WOULD THIS BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD PROMPT GRAND JURY
PROCEEDINGS?
.
>> WELL, BRIANNA, WE WERE
TALKING ON THE BREAK ABOUT THE
RELATIVE LIKELIHOOD OF FEDERAL
PROSECUTION WHERE THERE SHOULD
BE FEDERAL INVESTIGATION BUT
THERE HAS BEEN NO SIGNS DOJ IS
LOOKING AT THIS.
BUT STATE INVESTIGATORS LIKE
D.A. FANNING WILLIS IN FULTON
COUNTY, GEORGIA, HAS BEEN VERY
ACTIVE.
IN THE ATLANTA JOURNAL
CONSTITUTION THIS MORNING,
MYSELF AND MY CO-AUTHORS AT
BROOKINGS HAVE EXPLAINED THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS A SUBSTANTIAL
RISK.
WE DON'T PREDICT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
BUT WE GO THROUGH THE CRIMES,
BRIANNA.
HE IS AT SUBSTANTIAL RISK OF
PROSECUTION.
GUESS WHO ONE OF THE KEY
WITNESSES IS?
NONE OTHER THAN STEVE BANNON.
THIS IS BAD NEWS FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
AND WE KNOW THAT CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS SUBPOENAED BANNON,
AND THEY ARE TALKING TO THE
FULTON COUNTY D.A.
SO STORM CLOUDS AHEAD FOR THE
EX-PRESIDENT.
.
>> SO WE ARE SEEING THOSE FOUR
FORMER ADVISERS WHO ARE BEING
SUBPOENAED.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE MAY OR MAY NOT PLAY
INTO CONGRESS'S INVESTIGATION OF
WHAT HAPPENED JANUARY 6th.
IT SEEMS LIKE TRUMP AND HIS
ALLIES THINK OF IT AS A
LAWYER/CLIENT PRIVILEGE,
SOMETHING THAT ALWAYS PERSISTS
OVER TIME.
THAT IS NOT WHAT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IS.
IT IS NOT IN PLACE TO PROTECT
FORMER PRESIDENTS IN&CLOUD
WRONGDOING THEY MAY HAVE BEEN
PART OF WHILE THEY WERE
PRESIDENT.
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
LEANING TOWARDS NOT GOING SO FAR
IN EXERTING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
IN THESE COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
TRUMP AND HIS ADVISERS IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> AS WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT MANY
TIMES, THE LAW OF DONALD TRUMP
BEARS NO RESEMBLANCE TO THE
ACTUAL LAW OF THE LAND IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THE LAW OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IS THAT THERE IS ONLY
ONE PRESIDENT AT A TIME THAT
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE BELONGS TO
THE PRESIDENCY.
NOT TO ANY INDIVIDUAL NOW.
COURTS HAVE SAID THAT THERE'S A
DESIRABLE PRACTICE OF CONSULTING
WITH THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND
THE WHITE HOUSE INTENDS TO DO
THAT.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALREADY SIGNALED THAT IT IS
GOING TO WAVE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGES BECAUSE IT ALLOWED
TWO TOP TRUMP AIDES TO TESTIFY
TO CONGRESS.
HIS ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL MR.
ROSEN AND ROSEN'S DEPUTY, MR.
DONAHUE.
THAT IS THE MOST VALUABLE.
THAT IS USUALLY THE THING YOU
FIGHT THE HARDEST AGAINST, HUMAN
TESTIMONY.
NOW THE FIGHT IS GOING TO BE
ABOUT DOCUMENTS.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO TURN THOSE DOCUMENTS
OVER.
RIGHTLY SO.
AND, AGAIN, WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THOSE DOCUMENTS,
EVIDENCE OF POSSIBLE CRIMINAL
CONDUCT BY DONALD TRUMP AS STA